you don't have a chef's hat so we're in
other words the rat without the rat that
controls you you're like ah so right leg
two is a movie yes but where is this
English I know right so yeah there's
just never right in my life you're just
that good
thank God I'm gonna go right in the
kitchen my god that's good no there's
heavy I was going there
yeah I'm rich Brian and I'm Joe G and
we're back at feast mansion last season
we mastered the art of the French omelet
became world-class sushi chefs and ate a
bunch of bull testicles now that we're
master chefs we're bringing even more of
the ADI rising family along for round
two boys are out today because they suck
so I'm taking over today let's go
Indomie is not into me without these
guys whoever the [__] came up with these
I don't know why you're not the most
celebrated man on this earth I thought
it'd be fun to pull some noodles
together today this is really
mesmerizing this is great yeah
that's wild bro this season we've got
more special guests nothing better than
just hanging out in the kitchen with
your guys yeah taking pizza bites
getting major cheese poles that is
actually pig brain and it's thought that
if you eat pig's brain then you'll get
smarter why do we need to get smarter on
lioness own more piece of culinary
excellence boys oh look at that ass it
looks like a Picasso painting it's got
like char on it it's not Neapolitan it's
a piece manche pizza oh yeah then even
more Luda
that dudes kind of like it's kind of
like Giga Ramsay like it's kinda like
borderline abusive see that's why they
don't put too much [__] in my bill go
it's already happening I know at the
feast mansion it's all about pushing
culinary boundaries so I thought it
might be fun if we made a hot sauce
greatest [__] cooking show in the
world great his cooking show in the
world
great his cooking show him the [__]
world they I'm glad to be here at the
feast mansion greatest welcome the
cooking show in the world it's a
greatest honour in cooking the last
season we became really great chefs like
the best chefs of our generation there's
one thing that we still haven't
conquered I've seen the crab and
spongebob make the burgers before so I
hey I'd say it's like the same thing
welcome to the feast mansion welcome to
the feast mansion welcome to the feast
mansion
welcome to the feast mansion Gordon
Ramsay and Bobby Flay they called me and
they were like yo like can we be on the
show I said oh no that's ok what their
pizza sucks